hey leute befasst mit dem heutigen video
losgeht muss ich mal kurz was sagen und
zwar waren wir das heißt mag sich unsere
familie gestern noch maxis abiball
und was soll ich sagen die sache ist
bisschen länger geworden wir sind heute
erst um halb sechs ins bett gegangen bis
zu wenig geschlafen unter vier augen
gesprochen dass man nach so einer
verhandlung immer noch ein bisschen
besoffen aber ja deswegen wollen euch
nicht wenn ich heutigen video ein
bisschen ko wenn die gesagt gestern war
richtig lang gefeiert wohl einfach
bisschen platt deswegen sind kürzeres
video ich heute aber trotzdem etwas
bieten letzten zwei tage auch nicht
hochgeladen habe ja ich hoffe es freut
mich einfach und jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video services und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video heute zeige ich
euch wieder ein neues jump flexibel und
leute das heutige team ist richtig
richtig ob er ihr springen wir gerade
seht direkt in eine endrunde ein sind
auf der map farm und es gibt wieder was
zu zeigen das wieder was zu berichten
und zu haben wir ein neues secret
entdeckt bzw
nicht ich sondern diese linien mts ist
und diesel ihn würde es jetzt mal zeigen
nachdem ich hier den shader raus gemacht
habe wo sie da was entdeckt hat und ich
sag mal so der forscher nach diesem
wieder gezeigt hat ist das nicht
ziemlich ziemlich heiße sache du heißt
private public und bist schon gestorben
jetzt bist du okay alles darf dann ist
das sehr gut
gut dann von dem ok ist schon hier in
dem silo da oben das ist ein hobby da
setzt dieses item herausgenommen ist ein
holzschwerter wir fall entscheidet das
so wir schauen sie uns jetzt mal an und
es ist pironet schärfe 1 verbrennung 2
das ist ziemlich ziemlich ziemlich op
verbrennung 2 ist quasi feier respekt
leute es ist ein mega op effekt für
minecraft jumping zumindest ein paar
jahren reisen schwert schon sehr sehr
gutes item ist minecraft jump league
sind items sie in anderen spielmodi
jetzt 0.15 uhr durchschnitt werden muss
zb in eisen schwert ist ein blick
relativ gesehen schon ihr schwert sowie
so scharfes schwert es recht und
deswegen auch so was wie in versteckten
schartner absolut weil ihr so was
einfach
bekommt im normalen spiel also heute
wieder eine ganz klassische kurze secret
vorstellung mega mega op meiner meinung
nach würde ich sagen 525 angriff schaden
3 user ist glaube ich
wir werden jetzt noch versuchen die
runde zu gewinnen wie immer gilt auch
wenn ihr noch mehr erfahren wollt die
wenn zum beispiel die bereiche oder
sowas dann könnt ihr das gerne in die
kommentare schreiben lassen
daran orientiert nicht immer alles
gefallen weil ich gerne mehr davon ihr
zu suchen war damit etwas zu reißen soll
ja okay dann noch mal zwei oder zwei
gegner also sitzen to be to da können
wir dann gleich mal rein brechen und mit
unserem bei aspect schwert x 1 hits
setzen zum beispiel auf den hier so nice
da habe ich zum beispiel alle drei sind
es wirklich drei uses der brennt jetzt
halt mega fehler somit die jusos
bisschen taktisch ungünstig eingesetzt
aber es ist mega effektiv gerade weil
ihr euch im kampf nicht die zeiten
müssen fms zu platzieren und die gegner
damit richtig richtig gut beschädigen
können auf jeden fall dass wir daran
holen hat ihr leben hatte der gast jetzt
tatsächlich überlebte das schwert ist
gekommen
wtf das schwert wir gerade eben schon
kaputt an dieses zurück gekommen ok also
ist klar damit knapp hinten reindrücken
als ob das schwert zurückgekommen ist wo
ist der sinn
ich würde dir das bett ist eiskalte
kommt ja alles okay das ist jetzt auch
weg hier
und ja dann gibt es nur noch uns beide
schnell veit oder wie 59 sekunden
na ja als auch was die wenn ihr meinen
trick anwendet dann response schwer doch
einfach mal aus dem nichts vollkommen
sinnlos sehr gute stick wird wie gesagt
auf der map fahren bei den großen silos
einfach um rein weil ich euch nicht
vorenthalten ich habe es nie irgendwo
irgendwie miteinander beschreibung
verlinkt werden die wir abdecken wollte
und bis zum nächsten mal auch reinmacht
gut und ja